sur le terrain maintenant on ce conflit
en ukraine une ville est devenu le
nouveau symbole du bras de fer entre
kiev et moscou c'est vers donetsk dans
l'est ukrainien la région du lombard
quelques 500 civils seraient bloqués
dans un site industriel de la ville
quasi à siéger en compagnie de
combattants ukrainien pour faire le
point on retrouve notre envoyé spécial à
kiev bolling godard pauline bonjour
qu'est la situation ce mercredi à
severodvinsk
la bataille fait toujours rage à
severodonetsk 70% de la ville est
contrôlée par les russes c'est une
information qui a été confirmée par le
ministère de la défense britannique dans
son point quotidien sur la situation en
ukraine les soldats ukrainiens ont dû se
retirer du centre ville une grande
partie de ces soldats se sont retranchés
dans l'usiné chimique d'azo tilly a
également de nombreux civils ils
seraient environ 500 cette information a
également été confirmée par le ministère
de la défense britannique et par les
autorités ukrainiennes encore une fois
concernant ce chiffre d'environ 500
civils bloqués dans cette usine à gaz
hotte les russes ont annoncé hier la
mise en place vouloir mettre en place un
corridor humanitaire
il devait débuter à 7 heures heure de
paris se finir à 19h heure de paris mais
à une condition et bien que les soldats
ukrainien rendent les armes et ces
civils doivent être normalement évacués
vers une zone contrôlée par les russes
pour l'instant il est très difficile
d'avoir des informations sur ce qui se
passe exactement là bas concernant ce
corridor kiev n'a ni confirmé ni infirmé
belot dire meilleur élève qui a juste
dit hier et bien à ses troupes de tenir
le coup dans le donbass il faut donc
être très prudent par rapport à toutes
ces informations cela rappelle notamment
ce qui s'est passé à marioupol à l'
usine d'azov talent ou des combattants
était retranché où la russie avait
annoncé à plusieurs reprises la maison
croire de la mise en place de couloirs
humanitaires ces couloirs humanitaires
et bien tout ça ne s'était pas
concrétisée à l'époque qui avait moscou
ne faisait que se renvoyer la balle
bonjour pauline il y à de nombreuses
accusations de crimes guerre dans le
conflit à kiev les enquêteurs de
l'organisation des nations unies
s'apprêtent à tenir une conférence de
presse
oui cette conférence de presse doit être
donné en fin de matinée les enquêteurs
de la commission de l'onu des crimes de
guerre sont ici depuis le 7 juin ils ont
enquêté ils ont rencontré plusieurs
victimes ils ont recueilli des
témoignages ils se sont notamment rendus
à kharkhiv à kiev mais aussi abuja où
vous le savez de nombreuses exactions
ont été commises
nous nous trouvions nous encore il y a
deux jours à côté de boudhha nous avons
assisté à l'exhumation de sept corps qui
ont été découverts dans une fosse
commune les corps de cet homme qui
semble-t-il selon les premières
informations et est ce que nous avons pu
constater par nous mêmes c'est personnes
avaient été torturées certaines avaient
été exécutés d'une balle dans la tête
donc les les enquêteurs de l'onu doivent
aujourd'hui rendre leurs premières
conclusions sur ce qu'ils ont pu
recueillir comme témoignage aujourd'hui
c'était la première fois c'est la
première fois qu'il se rendait en
ukraine pour pouvoir enquêter sur ces
crimes de guerre et en suivra ça avec
vous depuis kiev pauline godard merci
pauline merci à catherine norris trent
et wassim dali qui sont avec vous
envoyés spéciaux de france 24